now the central point i want to make
here is
actually not about january 6th at all
but before we get to that point i do
have to review i feel like i must review
a few of the cringiest episodes
yesterday during the the left's january
6 festivities
it was destined already to be the most
insufferable day in american history and
i think it certainly lived up to that
billing so kicking off right away with
camila harris delivering a somber
address in remembrance of that day
while drawing direct comparisons between
a bunch of dummies trespassing in the
capital and pearl harbor listen
fellow americans good morning
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021.
well there you go pearl harbor 911 i
mean i'd say that almost basically
exhausts the list of bad things in
history that the average leftist is
aware of there there is one other she
didn't mention though
and that is the holocaust
but surely surely surely nobody would
ever be so egregious so utterly without
shame
as to actually compare january 6th to
the holocaust
surely nobody would do that you might
insist
and you would be wrong
dwight eisenhower during world war ii
made sure all the holocaust camps were
filmed so we've got the film footage so
now we're combating conspiracy theorists
deniers
and some um and you know trumpeteers
but
my worry is what do we call this and
make sure we we honor this day this dark
stained day every year so we've got to
keep saying january 6th i think it is
like december 7th pearl harbor and it is
like the 9 11 um tragedy and we also
have need to not be afraid to call the
trump insurrection of january 6 because
in the end all roads to what went wrong
that day lead to donald trump's ill
behavior his
anti-democratic stance he took the big
lie
after the presidential election tallies
came in and joe biden had won by
millions of votes
well now that we have that base covered
with all of the overwrought historical
analogies
what we need next are of course the
inspirational musical performances
unfortunately lin-manuel miranda and the
cast of hamilton they were on hand while
they were on zoom anyway
um
not not wearing masks which i thought
was very reckless and they were there to
serenade members of congress with a
rendition of whatever the hell this song
is
[Music]
[Music]
i'll make the world safe
[Music]
we'll make it right for you
if we
[Music]
and that was followed of course finally
by the requisite um candlelight vigil
and the somber and this time masked
performance of god bless america
[Music]
america
my home
sweetheart
by the way if you're wondering what
using the lord's name in vain looks like
or sounds like it's it's that that's
what it sounds like
it doesn't actually mean using the
lord's name that doesn't actually mean
using a phrase like damn in fact god
does damn things and there's nothing
wrong necessarily with pointing that out
if i were to say that i'm that i'm i'm
tired of of
damned gender theory being taught in
schools
which i am and it is
that's not taking the lord's name in
vain because gender theory is a damned
and damnable thing
but um there we have people singing the
name of god
in an empty
and manipulative way purely for
theatrics to score political points
that's what taking his name in vain
sounds like okay
but i digress
there is i think one fundamental point
that needs to be made about all of this
and here it is
january 6 2021
was a time when a group of useful idiots
did something very stupid
something that had zero chance of
producing any positive result whatsoever
positive for them any with it there was
nothing positive that could possibly
come out of it for them
them personally
politically
anything
and in doing that
those useful idiots provided ammunition
to the left
which the left will never stop using
ever
in fact as annoying as all this
pageantry is
it's almost pointless to complain about
it
because of course the left is going to
do this
sure the whole routine is cynical and
absurd
but what else do you expect them to do
a bunch of right-wing dummies rioted at
the capitol do we expect the left to say
hey you know what let's not make a big
deal out of this
let's just move on guys
is that what we expect them to do no
only republicans are stupid enough to
refuse a gift when their enemies hand it
to them
democrats are are gonna make hay that's
what they do
if you give them lemons they make
lemonade if you give them lemonade
to begin with then they'll just say
thank you and they'll sip from it
gratefully and repeatedly forever
it might not be honest or right morally
but it's smart politics
and and that's what they're doing with
january 6th
that's why when i look at what's
happened and how the narrative has
formed and i look at you know what
happened yesterday
i'm not nearly as angry at the democrats
as i am at the republicans
democrats again are using the ammunition
that they've been given
the hapless republicans will whine about
it but rather than whining they should
be doing the exact same thing with the
blm riots
all of the time
that the democrats spend talking about
january 6th
republicans should be spending the exact
same amount of time talking about the
blm riots and in that case it would not
be dishonest or cynical because unlike
january 6th the blm riots of 2020 were
in fact an assault on our way of life
our civilization
our democracy if you like
they were deadly
they were actually deadly they were
catastrophic they were unthinkably
tragic
and they were supported every step of
the way by every elected democrat in the
country
explicitly supported
the blm riots resulted in 25 deaths
dozens of injuries
two billion dollars of damage across the
country
they sparked a crime surge that still
hasn't died away
they were several several orders of
magnitude worse than january 6 worse in
every way by every conceivable metric
okay
they had exactly the destabilizing
effect on our system that january 6th
allegedly had but didn't really have
it's not a coincidence that crime is
running rampant in many of the cities
where these riots occurred the criminals
learned that they could get away with
this kind of thing they could get away
with violence arson looting and so on
and they've taken that message to heart
the blm riots therefore have a lasting
impact and a relevance that january 6th
does not have
nobody is it's not like there are going
to be more riots at the capitol nobody
is ever riding at the capitol ever again
okay that much is guaranteed
the people who took part in in that
are paying dearly for it
paying much more dearly than they should
actually according to how the law is
written they're being overcharged but
the blm riots rioters have paid almost
no price at all
so they've learned the exact opposite
lesson
this is why the blm riots represent an
ongoing existential threat in a way that
january 6 does not
and never did and never could it never
will
and while most people on the right
condemned january 6 while it was
happening i mean almost everybody did
except for the people that were there in
the building
everybody else said this is you
shouldn't be doing this like obviously
you should be riding at the capitol
um
but that hasn't happened on the left on
the left most people supported blm and
still do to this day
without apology
see this is not what about ism just to
be clear
bringing up blm is not what about ism
bringing up january 6th is what about
ism
because that is the irrelevant thing
used to distract from the more important
thing
and this is a point that republicans
could make
and they could keep making
over and over again
they could have candlelight vigils for
the officers killed or injured by blm
they could have days of remembrance they
could have memorial services
they could give speeches
you know they could make sure that
nobody ever forgets the date
when retired retired police captain
david dorn was shot in cold blood by a
blm milton during a riot
or the date when blm militants invaded a
police station in minneapolis and burned
it to the ground while the officers ran
for their lives
republicans could do that
but they don't i mean they could talk
about it incessantly constantly so that
nobody ever forgets and that each
democrat responsible for encouraging it
is held responsible branded with it
has to wear it around their necks for
life they could do that
but they don't
because they are feckless hapless
incompetent and scared
what else is new
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated